ses excuses étaient attendues depuis des
décennies après le refus de ses
prédécesseurs le pape françois
finalement prononcé libre aux
historiques
sont mortes à doha
il a écouté les témoignages des
survivants des pensionnats toute la
semaine lorsqu'il venu le temps de
prendre la parole le chef de l'église
catholique a fait plus que présenter ses
excuses
il le dit toute la haute et la douleur
qu'il ressentait en pensant au rôle que
plusieurs congrégations catholiques ont
joué dans les pensionnats un traitement
des enfants autochtones et ding des
enseignements de jésus christ dit le
pape pour continuer de faire avancer la
réconciliation
chez ingram n'est pas françois réitère
aussi son engagement devenir bientôt ou
non seulement au canada mais aussi en
territoire autochtone cette visite
pourrait faire aussi tôt qu'en juillet
marqués dans leur chair et dans leur
esprit et survivants et leurs
descendants ont été touchés droite au
coeur par les mouches du saint père
la présidente de la délégation aux
métiers s'oubliera jamais le moment
qu'elle a partagée avec une survivants
des pensionnats
les autochtones se sont longtemps sentis
et puissants face à l'église catholique
aujourd'hui c'est toute leur humanité
longtemps ignoré quitté réaffirmé gansa
ses excuses
si limoux du pape agissent comme un boom
oui exact à 10 heures accueil des fans
de son père policier les autochtones
souligne qu'il s'agit d'abord et avant
tout d'une première étape dans le chemin
de la guérison et de la réconciliation
ils attendent encore le pack prépayé
mouche chez eux sur les terres
ancestrales tincu et le match v site bye
bye
l'église catholique canadienne reconnaît
qu'il reste du travail à faire mais
souligne l'importance de ce jalon on va
continuer dans ce sens là et évidemment
que pour ce qui est du saint-père
première grande étape ce matin cent
cinquante mille enfants ont été arrachés
à leur famille pour être envoyés dans
les pensionnats et au moins quatre ils
sont morts à cause des mauvais
traitements subis si ces excuses
historiques du pape n'effaceront jamais
ce lourd passé elle permet de commencer
à guérir les profondes blessures qui
subsistent encore à ce jour ici mathieu
cueillez radio canada rob